heart stopper season two open call now i
love this because i feel like i could
actually breathe life into this role
casting for the role of sahar zaheed
there you go
sahar zaheed actor must be a minimum age
of 16
uh playing age 16. ben i don't want to
put you under too much pressure could
you find like sides or and that's the
industry terminology for some type of
script or
what because i'm literally not on the
show we are going to film an audition
for zahar
hadid
a 16 year old in the netflix show heart
stopper and look see look i kind of look
like zahara hadid you don't go go look i
want now you focus in on zahara deed
there you go not too far off that's
actually kind of perfect you get a pair
of ben's golf pants yes an old sweater a
wig one of the you know so what get get
maurice's wig by the way i love that
this is an open call this
would be like several years ago this
would be the photo in a health book of a
person that needed to really like work
out yeah this would be a before picture
before picture they'd go for example as
you can see
molly has been eating too much
she needs to stop eating but so now ben
what do they want here from uh zahar
uh sahar zaid we're looking for a
plus-sized actor of british south asian
heritage who identifies as female or
non-binary now by the way let's all just
for fun imagine that coming across the
desk of an executive lion's gate in 1992
1992 it comes across miramax it's harvey
weinstein's desk
and they go we want a plus-size actor of
british south asian heritage who
identifies as female or non-binary and
harvey wants he goes the hell we do yeah
so okay i'm by the way
professional experience is not essential
let's talk for a minute about the
direction that this shitty business
we've gone in has chosen because this is
actually kind of stunning yes it's kind
of stunning right this is a hit show on
netflix right it's one of their biggest
shows they go we are looking for a fatty
bombati
whose british south asian heritage who
identifies as female or non-binary
professional experience is not essential
meaning you don't have to be an actor or
an actress to be on our hit show to be
on our hit show you just have to be
non-binary or a
fatty boom baddie that's all you got to
do and i i mean
start saharas in year 11
at higgs no-nonsense independent a
little cynical at times that well sure
i'd be cynical too because i'm not an
actor or actress yeah and yet i'm on
this show yeah
now listen i'm not i'm gonna say
something here that's gonna get me in
trouble but the person who answers this
call if they're not an actor or actress
should be raped because the reality is
what are you there for like i would be
like you're gonna molest my kid if i was
the parent they don't have to be an
actor actress just send them on in
uh if you feel you're right for this
role we would love to hear from you via
email only please send a recent photo a
little bit about yourself and contact
details ben got a photo of me recently
no we're sending this right now we're
sending this right now i've had enough
let's make an email i'm sick of being
limited yeah and it said that daniel
edwards casting is committed to yes
what are they committed to thank god
wait hold on read this chris please
daniel edwards casting is committed to
equal opportunities for all performers
regardless of gender race disability
religion or sexual orientation except on
the first page they said you have to be
yes fat indian from [ __ ] britain
right so that's what so yeah what are
you talking about daniel edwards yeah
daniel edwards is a big fat liar liar
and but here's the deal i love gulab
jamun which is an indian little uh donut
that spits uh it spits like uh syrup
okay um because have you ever had gulab
jamun i i thought that was the new d.a
of new york
[Laughter]
it is
but so
my point is that who's to say what is
and isn't right
you know i identify as non-binary
because because some days i feel like a
little bit of [ __ ] sure and sometimes i
feel like a dude so i am none but i'm
coming out now i'm kind of coming and
i've said this before right being gay
isn't enough
so i'm i'm non-binary now which means
gay plus film i'm in movies that's what
i wanted what does actually non-binary
mean you're not you're genderless you're
you're not a man or a woman you're in
the mix you're on the spectrum like
which used to just be called a human
being who has different gender feelings
all the time like we all do right
sometimes you feel more masculine
sometimes you feel more feminine right
this also doesn't make any sense because
the people that usually say it also go
gender is not real at all sure so what
is this binary of this thing that
doesn't i don't know well it gets tough
because i had i had a very very person
you know non-binary one of uh my kid's
mom's family members very woke right all
that you know talking i had a big pool
party a couple of weeks ago yes right on
the heels of the roe v wade stuff i know
that shit's controversial but what i
will say it's in the pool we had t.t
jerry who's transgender you know on on a
rubber ducky float saying screaming that
life begins at conception right
and then and then this person said the
woke said said you can't say anything
about it you can't say anything about it
you were you're a man and she goes no no
no tj said i'm a woman i identify as a
woman so you said it right because i'm a
woman i can speak on these you know what
kurt metzger calls that
an intersectional car crash yes that's
what kurt metzger calls what it is an
intersectional car crash here we go this
is a photo of me
and it's just too
open call at daniel what's right here
let me just say this comes across my
desk i'm not immediate if you said if
you said
you know if i was daniel edwards casting
which is committed to racial equality i
would say this isn't necessarily not
a south asian
woman yes you have a south asian glow a
huge
glow and a hue you could be this could
be you know where that's from that's
from remember the show at arlene's
grocery oh of course new york city
that's a photo i believe it might be a
mindy tucker oh she's the best man he
talked about
that yeah yeah somebody during the riot
somebody threw a molotov cocktail
through arlene's grocery really swear to
god yeah down in that area yeah but it
was a fun little venue it was a fun
little it was rebecca trent
so now here's what i want to craft i
want to craft an email because now get
this thing up ben what what do they want
because they've asked for certain things
in the email please send a recent photo
a little bit about yourself and contact
details
um
okay we're so listen to this oh dude
that last part is funny too let's go
back to the last part yeah let's read
the whole thing daniel edwards cassidy
is committed to equal opportunities for
all performers regardless of gender race
disability religion or sexual
orientation where gender height race or
appearance has been specified we can
confirm such characteristics are a
genuine requirement for the role so
where we are saying
that you have to be something it's a
genuine requirement for the role but
yeah we're committed to equal
opportunities for all performers yeah
unless which by the way it's hilarious
to me because the second part of it it's
like well of course of course it's like
why don't if danielle was casting just
[ __ ] be honest just say just put a
picture up of pumbaa from the lion king
and say this is what the person needs to
look like
okay ben i want you to tell them
about myself okay okay yeah
um
first thing i would say i'm over 18.
i am overweight
and i'm over not being on your show lol
[Laughter]
i am not
south asian
i mean christ almighty with him
i am not south asian but
now keep the period okay but all cops
okay
but
now i gotta kind of prove my bona fides
as a south asian non-binary person right
now okay now
what is south asian non-binary people
like what do what does a south asian
non-binary person what would they like
yeah south asian non-binary based in the
uk what would i would say they would
like fire island
they like the movie fire island
okay okay i'm over 18 and i'm overweight
and i'm over not being going to show lol
i am not south asian but i love gulab
jamun there you go is this all caps no
but south asian means indian right is
that what we're saying yes and others
and theo i would say but i love sula
gulab salmon gulab jamun g-a-u-l-a-b
uh
j-a-m-u-n i love gulab jamun i love
gulab jamun and i also and i love hasan
minaj's homecoming king yes i love
hassan minaj's homecoming king on
netflix on netflix yes
i also
homecoming king on netflix yes
yep okay but i love gulab jamun and i
love hasan minaj's homecoming king on
netflix
the
the skills i bring to the role are
being fat
[Laughter]
next sentence
[Laughter]
i am
also very
happy
to work
with a team of people
that really value diversity there you go
for this role
i will need
to put on brown makeup
and i will do so tastefully
there you go
because of skin problems
can you type any faster
because of skin problems it must be all
natural makeup
we also need to come up with a plan yeah
because we will be accused
of doing quote brownface
yes
however
however
when people realize
that i am quote that [ __ ]
100 that [ __ ] okay
they will forgive us
okay
sincerely
tim dillon
now go two lines down go
tim dillon
is a non-binary
[Laughter]
south asian
woman
[Laughter]
a south
asian male tim dillon is a non-binary
male presenting south asian woman there
you go very good nailed it yeah it's
good
who is committed
to fat activism
comma
equality
comma
equity
comma
inclusivity
comma
communism
comma
overthrowing
the patriarchy ben hit return yeah yeah
indent
an opponent might look
weird overthrowing
the heteronormative
white
patriarchal
capitalistic
violent
oppressive
eco-terrorists
jews no don't put that that's a joke
that's a joke now i'm kidding about that
yeah
okay tim dillon is a non-binary male
presenting south asian woman who's
committed to fat activism equality
equity inclusivity communism
overthrowing the heteronormative violent
oppressive uh
uh oil just say petro uh say uh uh
it's the violent oppressive petro narco
state
there you go there you go
send
send send it
what's the subject line here um i put
tim dillon submission but your lucky day
now i wish they had uh sides for me but
i don't think they care if i'm actually
an actor or actress you have to be uk
based which is it's all
it's interesting hello
um i'm in the uk you know i'm fat and
brown